The following content is
provided under a Creative
Common License.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality, educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So today is the final lecture,
and I'm going to talk to about
the future.
If I can figure out how to
get the slides going.
Predicting the Future is always
not a simple thing.
And especially this day and
age we are -- things are
appearing on the internet, so
this is getting recorded and
on the internet.
And I'm going to make a few
comments that in five years
time, I'm going to regret.
What I'll try to do is try to
have a systematic process
through that.
Because I know you guys
are great hackers.
You guys are great programers.
You and any problem,
you can solve it.
But as researchers, what's
hard, and what's very
difficult, is to figure out
which problem to solve.
Because as Roderick pointed out,
when we started on Raw in
about '97, there was a raging
debate what to build.
And there's group of people who
say we can build bigger
and bigger superscalars.
In fact, there was this
article, very seminal
proceedings that came out,
that basically asked many
people to contribute, saying
what do they think will a
billion transistor processor
look like?
And about 2/3 of them said, we
would have this gigantic,
fabulous superscalar.
And about three out of about
ten, I think about three
groups said that, OK, it would
be more like tiled
architecture.
The Stanford people and
us are the main
people who look at that.
So even that short time, 10
years ago, it was not sure
what's going to happen.
And so we took a stance
and spent 10
years working on that.
We were lucky, more than
anything else, that ITV had a
little bit better insight,
hopefully, but also mostly a
larger dose of luck
we get here.
So part of that is how do
you go about doing this?
So future ia a combination of
evolution and revolutions.
Evolution is somewhat
easy to predict.
Basically, what you can look
at is, you can look at the
trends going on and you can
extrapolate that trend.
And you can say, if this trend
continue, what will happen?
If this trend continue
what will happen?
It's very interesting in
computer science because one
thing I do in 6033 is look at
the rate of evolution that
happens in computer science, and
trying to predict it with
things like the rate
of [OBSCURED]
and stuff like that and you
get ridiculous numbers.
So even if it is evolution, in
computer science it's very
close to revolution.
Because every 18 months
things double.
That's almost unheard of.
In a lot of areas, every 18
months you get 1% improvement
and people are very happy.
This is doubling.
We have that.
THe other part is revolutions.
If some completely new
technological solution just
come about and completely
change the world.
Change how things happen.
These are a lot harder
to predict.
But still it's critically
important because some of
these things can have
huge impact.
And so we will more focus on
evolution and if we have at
the end we can see if we
have some interesting
revolutionary ideas.
Paradigm shifts occur in both.
You don't have to wait
for a revolution to
have something different.
Because things like 2x
improvement type things that
happens, actually brings
paradigm shifts on a very
regular basis.
So it's not 1% we
are a getting.
We are getting huge
evolution changes.
And that can keep
changing things.
So what I'm going to talk
to you about, a
little bit of trends.
Some of it is repetitive.
I spent sometime in
the first lecture
talking about these trends.
And then we'll look at
two different parts.
One is architecture side,
what can happen next.
And languages, compilers
and tools side.
We'll spend a little bit of time
on revolution, and just
see that we have group
brainstorming.
And then I have this little bit
of a my preview of what
people should be doing, very
broad level, and I'll finish
off with that.
So look at trend.
I think there are a lot
of interesting trends
that we can look at.
Moore's law, which is a very
trusting trend that keep going
for a very long time.
Power consumption, wire delay,
hardware complexity,
parallelizing compilers, program
design methodologies.
So you have all these trends
her to look at.
I have this picture, the graph
on the right, which shows what
happened at every generation,
assume this is a generation.
You concentrate on the hardest
problem, what's the most
taxing thing?
And what happens is as you go,
at this time, something like
this might be the taxing, and
then that generation, that's
where all the design going on.
Then some slowly growing things
start catching up, and
then, after some time, that
becomes the most important
thing in the design.
So it's a paradigm shift,
because you move that focus on
that, that becomes the
important thing.
And then some fast moving things
start catching up and
accelerate, and that becomes
our most taxing thing.
And then this thing, again, and
the different curves start
catching up again.
So what happens is you have this
cyclic phenomenon, too.
But also you have the discrete
So you might get into a
revolutionary thing, and really
bring something down.
For example, we went from
very power-hungry,
bipolar devices to SEMOS.
And suddenly everything
shifted down a lot.
And then we are back
again, we are those
power-hungry days again.
So that was kind of
a revolutionary
change and get evolution.
If you want to do work on
something, it's no fun working
on something that's very
important, hot today.
The people who are making the
biggest breakthroughs on the
things that are hot today,
started 10 years ago.
So your finally figure out
that this is the most
important technology today, I'm
going to start working on
doing my Ph.D. By the time you
are done, it'll be passe, most
of these cyclic things.
So the key thing is, what is
going to be hot in 10 years?
That's a hard problem.
So this is the thing you can
look at these trends, and say,
look, these are the
kind of trends.
This can give you some idea
where what might be
interesting.
So are you going to become
a low power person?
For example, six, seven years
ago, people who studied low
power, they made a lot of
significant contributions.
People now still
can contribute.
But people who got in early had
an easier time, and they
had a lot more impact then
people who got in late.
So we look at some of these
trends, and see what we can
come up with.
The first trend, this is a very
trust trend so far, is
Moore's Law.
Basically, most of our basis for
things happening is part
of Moore's Law.
Basically it says, you get
twice the number of
transistors every 18 months.
We have had that trend
for a very long time.
What's the impact of function?
Nobody cares about processors
who can't use transistors,
it's some kind of closed,
you don't even know many
transistors are in
the processor.
What matters is what
it can deliver.
So performance is what?
Delivery.
So what people have realized
is if you are in the
superscalar world, this has been
flattening out recently.
If you look at it, this is kind
of getting flat and that
was a big problem.
So that's kind of the reason for
crossover for superscalar,
I mean multicore.
So we are trying to get back
into again a higher growth
curve in here.
And then another
trend is power.
Power had been going in the
wrong direction and also power
density has been going in
the wrong direction.
This current keep growing more
than this and then people have
problems in that.
Something that is really
revealing is what's per spec
performance.
That means how much power you
are consuming to do something.
And what you see is, we are
just starting to --
these days we use very little
power to get work done, and
now we, what superscalars
did was be more and more
[OBSCURED].
And this is what, I think, led
to a big reason for going into
multicores.
Because we realized, look, we
keep wasting and now the power
consumption of computers
are non-trivial.
You could talk to Google.
Their power costs, power
budgets, is non-trivial.
We can't just keep wasting
that resource.
You can keep wasting things when
it is not that important,
smaller factor, but power
becomes a big factor.
So how do we get out of
the wasteful mode?
And I think that -- a
lot of people are
I'm looking at that.
If you talk to people five
years ago, people
say, this is free.
Transistors are free.
You can just keep
doing things.
Just keep them available,
[OBSCURED]
makes it free.
But what people realize is,
wire transistors are free,
switching them is not free.
And switching the request
file, so power become an
important issue.
At that point I want to point
out was this wire delay.
As we keep switching them faster
and faster, the world
looks smaller and smaller
and smaller, you
can make global decisions.
What the implication of that?
And we're facing that, I
think it's going to get
a little bit worse.
One saving grace for that is
people realize they can keep
scaling the clock speeds
that much.
This chart I did a few years
ago, still is a road map,
that's made the silicon
people think where
the silicon is going.
Thought they can get to
10 gigs, then 15 gigs,
and stuff like that.
And now they [OBSCURED],
and go to all of these
power requirements.
They might not be able to switch
that fast. So there are
changes to road map
because of that.
Another interesting
thing is --
AUDIENCE: RC line type wire
delay, as opposed to --
that's not speed of light
delay, that's including
scaling of the wires
themselves?
PROFESSOR: This is mainly
speed of light delay.
Because what you do is you just
look at clock speeds.
I haven't done too much
of dialectrical
and stuff like that.
That's the thing, you can get
closer to the speed of light
but right now we are
only about --
I mean we are not even a factor
of, I don't know, 80%,
90% speed of light.
So best case we can
get 10% better.
It doesn't give you
that much of room.
And this is a continuous thing,
because microprocessors
are going much faster
than d-RAM.
And this is having a problem.
There are people says there
might be revolutionary things
happening here.
Things like non-volatile RAM,
might come and kind of take
over this area.
What happening today is d-RAM
now looks a lot more like a
disc looked like 10 years ago.
In may ways.
We have to treat a d-RAM
like a disc.
That's kind of the way we have
of looking at the world.
Here where I look at compilers
and parallelizing.
There's no nice number here.
So in somewhere around the
1970s, people did things like
vectorization --
question?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the last slide.
When people do this plot which
is performance, it's not
exactly performance that or
throughput that matters
relative to d-RAM, it is the
computation lengths that is
how fast from when I know I want
something from memory to
when I really, really need
it that matters.
Is this going to change as we
move to a wider architecture,
with more parallelism, in the
sense that it will no longer
be, the lazy gap won't be
increasing anymore and we'll
start to hear more
about bandwidth?
PROFESSOR: I don't
know, because
bandwidth is also power.
These are a lot of interesting
arguments, this is what you
don't know.
Because the thing is, what
superscalar people did was, we
reduced the problem with
latency by predicting.
And doing extra work.
We will try as much as possible
to predict what you
need and do things in advance.
What happens is as you keep
predicting more and more,
you're actually doing,
your accuracy of
predictions go low.
But you still keep
increasing --
the more data you at least get a
small percentage increase in
useful data.
Effecting latency.
But accuracy start pretty
low and it start
becoming not useful.
So bandwidth problem
has an impact, too.
So unless you're using inside
the entire thing, you're
predicting a huge amount of
things, predicting that you
might use it.
So if the prediction is wrong,
it's a lot of wasteful work.
And the key thing is can
you pay by power?
I think latency, at some point,
if you can really
predict, it becomes hard.
Unless you have very regular
patterns that the predictions
working there.
If you look at what happened in
compiling and programming
technology.
In the '70s, you gets
vectorization technology.
It did well.
And then some time in 80's we
did things that compile for
instruction level parallelism.
That got a lot of parallelism
in there, very low, low
parallelism in there.
And somewhere in 90's we did
automatic parellelization
compilers for FORTRAN.
I think that was today almost
the highlight of that.
Because what happened was we
figured out how to get the
program language in FORTRAN
and do pretty well
automatically extract
patterns.
Then things were kind of down in
front there because people
say FORTRAN is interesting,
but we don't program in
FORTRAN anymore.
We are going to program
in things like C, C .
That did two things.
First of all, one is a language
problem, which is C,
C was unfortunately was not
a typesafe language.
It was not be given up the right
scientific application.
More like operating system
hacking, that required looking
at the entire address space.
That really hindered
the compiler.
Second, programmers start
falling in love with complex
data structures.
The world is not fixed
size arrays any more.
They want to develop
things, have
different structures, trees.
These things are much
harder to analyze.
So suddenly you can do it nicer,
they said, look, people
are doing recursions and these
very complex structures and
suddenly, the more of the things
you can go went down
pretty drastically.
And you're back to a
pretty bad state.
And then we're slowly recovering
a little bit
because things like JAVA and
C Sharp gave a typesafe
language, became a little
more analyzable.
I think automatically what you
can do kind of improves.
And the hope here is a demand
driven by multicores There's
no supply technology but
there's the demand.
You need to do something.
And hopefully there'll be
interesting things that come
about because of the demand.
So this is my prediction,
where things are.
What happened then and what's
going to happen next.
Of course, multicores
are here.
There's no question
about that.
But I don't think programmers
are ready for that.
I mean we have established a
very nice, solid boundary
between hardware and software.
Nice abstraction layer.
Most programmers don't have
to worry about hardware.
Programmers didn't have any
knowledgeable about the process.
In fact, we are moving
in that direction.
JAVA said you don't even
have to know about the
class of the program.
We are running this thing in a
nice high-level byte code.
Write once, run everywhere.
That's a very nice
abstraction.
For most types, more slow
actually gave you enough
performance, that that
was good enough.
We can deal with that.
The nice artifact of that is
programmers were oblivious to
what happened in processors.
A program written in
1970 still works.
Still will run 10
times faster.
That is really great.
If you look at Windows Office
that probably [OBSCURED].
We still have code written
in 1970, but in 1980.
There's still code in there.
Every time they tout they have
this completely new program.
Only probably 10% of
new code is there.
But that's not true for
the cell phone.
Every time they say I have a
new cell phone, most of the
time actually rewritten
completely.
So that's why in an industry
like that it's very hard to
evolve like that because we are
just churning too much.
And in soft ware we got really
enamored by this ability to
reuse stuff.
Ability to have this nice
abstraction in there.
And the problem is there's
probably a lot of freedom for
programmers, so they push
on complex issues.
So your question about how large
companies want complex
things, they way people get
their computer advantage is
pushing the complexity.
So what they did was, instead
of pushing the complexity in
the processor, they push the
complexity in software,
features and stuff like that.
So we are still on the
brink of complexity.
But now we are adding another
complexity that's very
hard to deal with.
So this is where things came
about, how things move.
Where can we go?
I want to talk about two
different parts.
Architecture, and languages,
compilers and tools.
Most of the things I talk about,
That's no solution.
This is what I think that will
happen, should happen.
I think that can hopefully
really inspire
people to go do that.
And hopefully I don't have to
eat what I say in 10 years.
One thing now about novel
opportunities in multicores is
you don't have to contend
with uniprocessors.
Most of the time they are a
source of big pain when you
are doing research in here.
Everybody says, yeah, that is
very nice, but I just wait two
years and this will happen
for me automatically.
Why do I have to worry about
your complex whatever you are
suggesting in there.
The other thing is, in the good
old days, the people who
really wanted performance
were these
really performance weenies.
In fact, you probably got a good
talk from a performance
weenie last time, who's
[OBSCURED].
And we want just performance
at all cost. There
are people like that.
For them, producing anything
it's not easy.
They say, I don't want tools.
They just suck my
performance out.
And it was very hard to
help them, because
they don't want help.
But right now what's
happening this is
becoming everybody's problem.
I think that will lead people
to want the things to take
advantage of parallelism.
The other thing is, the
problem can change.
Because people worked for 20
years or 40 years on this
parallel problem, but that's
for multiprocessors.
So how does this problem
has changed?
What's the impact from going
from a multiprocessor, which
is multiple chips, sitting on
a board, with some kind of
interconnecting to multiple
cores on the same die.
OK.
I think there are some very
substantial things that
happen, that can have
big impact.
Let's look at two of them.
Which is communication
bandwidth and
communication latency.
I think this is where you can
have revolutionary kind of
things happening.
If you look at communication
bandwidth, the best you could
get, if you put two chips on
any kind of a board, it's
about 32 gigabits per second.
Because you had to go through
pins and pins
had a lot of issues.
Today if you try to put two
different cores next to each
other in the same die, the
bisection bandwidth is huge.
It's four orders of magnitude
huge, that's what you can get.
That's a huge change.
Even for the lowest 2x
improvement, this is four
orders of magnitude difference
you can do.
So why is that?
Because what changes number
of wires in the die.
Because, if you think about
it, one name type of
architectures is to just just
build, to deal with this
reduction of communication
bandwidth.
The closed resistors
communicates the most, the
local memory next, and
then remote memory.
And then if you had
to go remote to
the next guy, network.
These things basically
reduce the amount of
things you can do.
That was really true.
Because if you you're
inside the chip, you
can do a lot more.
The minute you go to the
board, you can do less.
Minute you go to multiple
boxes, less.
Stuff like that.
That is the way the processor
would decide.
And also the clocks.
Being a processor you can do
much faster to go pins, not
that fast. People are trying
to change that, but still
that's an issue.
And multiplexing, because pins
were inherently limited.
If you have thousand pins
that's a big processor
basically in there.
And within a die, a thousand
wires is basically nothing.
So we have four orders of
magnitude improvement in here.
And that's amazing.
That can have a huge
impact in here.
So you can do massive
data exchange.
On big issue right now in
parallelism is the minute you
parallelize something, you
might slow it down.
Because the thing is, you might
not get data locality.
Because that pipe is going to
get clogged up because you've
been trying to take too
much data in there.
So if you put wrong things,
you're going to get clogged by
the communication panel.
This thing says, I might not
have to deal with that.
For example, I don't know why
you want to do that, but if
you want to move your entire
cache from one core to
another, you can probably do
it in a few clock cycles.
That is bandwidth.
I don't know why you want to
do that, because that's
probably not memory efficient,
power efficient.
But you can do it.
We have wireless.
So the key thing is
how can you take
advantage of these wires.
And how can you make it in a
way you can really use the
difficulty in programming,
because, as you've figured
out, parallel programming
is hard.
If you make a wrong decision,
you're going
to pay a huge price.
How can you make that in a way
that you can make a few wrong
decisions and get everything by
taking advantage of that.
I think that will be a big
opportunity in here.
Another opportunity
is latency.
This is not as big as bandwidth
because latency has
the inherent speed
of light issue.
Again, what happens
is now length of
wires are a lot shorter.
And no multiplexing,
so you can get a
direct wire from there.
And on-chip can be
much closer.
And the other interesting
things you
can also think about.
Right now, why is register
to register
communication just very fast?
In a processor if you send
something one way this can use
it almost instantaneously
is much faster.
Of course, wires are not
that, it's very close.
Also there are a lot of
other things we do.
We need more register, register
before we even come
to the data.
In a normal pipeline
machine you have
a pretty long pipeline.
The data is externally
receivable at the end of the
pipeline, but I can speculate
the same to the next one when
you start working on it if
you're wrong, I would yank it
out and you have give
[OBSCURED].
But right now if you actually
go across processors, we can
use speculation.
You have to wait until the
things are committed to
memory, and then you
can start using it.
That's even longer than ideally,
because that's like
10, 15 cycles I have to wait.
Why can't I send something
speculative to my neighbor?
I have enough bandwidth
to deal with it.
If I do something wrong,
can I speculate
across multiple cores.
So I can get my data
much faster.
I save probably an order of
magnitude beyond my wire delay
because I have no pipeline
stages made until [OBSCURED]
happens, very long later.
Things like that, can I
do in modern process?
Because no, I'm putting these
darn things next to each
other, what can I
do with that?
And you can do ultrafast
[OBSCURED]
real time and they can use
-- can I do things a lot
fine-grain across and take
advantage of that?
So the way to look at that a
traditional microprocessor
basically had this structure.
Cache memory and processor
cache memory.
And this is there because to
deal with a small amount of
wireless power and
stuff like that.
Today what we have done is
basically taken this
structure, and kind of put
it in the same die.
OK.
We haven't thought
beyond that.
And we get a few order,
a few factors better.
Because, no, I don't have to go
through the pin because now
I can have instead of say 128
pins, I can have 512 going in,
or 1,024 going in there.
But still, I have 4 orders of
magnitude freedom in here.
I am not using any of those.
So one thing Raw tried to do
is have a much more tightly
coupled, a lot more
communication going on there.
So a lot of people
say that today.
The biggest problem in
multicores is the network.
Because how will I build that
scale of a network?
My feeling is that's baloney.
Network is not an issue.
In fact, in Raw, a lot of our
experiments we could never
saturate a very, very
well done network.
Because in a network I have so
many pins, I can keep adding
bandwidth like crazy.
The problem the way people
design processor code today is
to minimize communication
going out of it.
It has a very thin memory bus
going in and out of it.
That memory bus can never
saturate any kind of network
you can build on a
microprocessor.
It matches well if you have to
go through the pins, because
it partially measures that.
But within the die you have
so much more bandwidth.
So I think something interesting
would be a
fundamental sign of what the
microprocessor looks like.
The core looks like.
It's not taking a Pentium and
kind of plopping it once, or
plumping it four times.
A Pentium is not any kind of a
nice processor, it evolved
over the years to basically
deal with this very thin
memory bandwidth.
And suddenly you've got
four [OBSCURED]
and that problem goes away.
And we're still saying, OK yeah,
I have this entire thing
in there, but I only want four
wires out of you, or 1,024
wires when you can give me
a hundred million wires.
That is the question.
So I think they'll be some
interesting things that the
people can make a big impact
trying to figure out how to
take advantage of that.
And by doing that, really
reducing the burden for the
programmer.
Right now, you say, ok look, I
am taking advantage of that,
but I'm passing on the buck
to the programmers.
They're dealing with all the
small interconnectary.
Then we say, you can't
just that because
programming is hard.
How can I reduce the programmer
burden by taking
advantage of that.
I think this is a very
interesting to
looked at this problem.
If you're doing any architecture
kind of research
or are interested in that,
here is an open problem.
I have this huge bandwidth out
there, and I have evolved
something that is completely in
the way dealing with very
limited amount of bandwidth,
but that's why they
live for this long.
And the minute you open it up,
how can I do with that?
I don't think we have a model.
And I think a lot
of interesting
can come out there.
OK.
Let's switch to language,
compilers and tools.
The way you look at it, what's
the last big thing that
happened in languages?
I think one that happens is
object oriented revolution.
The interesting thing about
object oriented revolution is
it didn't happen in a vacuum.
It happened because a lot of
interesting research in
academia and outside
went into it.
People didn't come up
and say, wow, it's a
great I'm writing Java.
There were hundreds of languages
that developed and
explored these concepts.
And the interesting thing about
programming is, a lot of
things that looks very neat and
interesting, when you look
at it first time when you start
using it in a media-line
program, that has been evolve
over 10 years, you realize
that's a pretty bad concept.
Can anybody think about a
concept that looks very
interesting at the beginning,
but actually very
hard to deal with.
AUDIENCE: My last program.
PROFESSOR: I haven't
heard that analogy
before but what else?
AUDIENCE: Exceptions.
PROFESSOR: Exceptions,
I think people still
haven't figured out.
I think one thing people have
made assumptions think of
multiple integrators.
With multiple integrators, the
first step, wow this is the
best thing since sliced bread,
because the thing object
oriented programming does is it
forces this one hierarchy,
and the world is objects,
but there's no one
hierarchy in the world.
World has these multiple
interconnections in there and
so people say, this is great.
This basically now give you
objects and you can get a lot
of different relationships.
But, after people trying to deal
with multiple integrators
they realize this is a pain.
It's very hard to understand
it, it's very hard to right
compilers, there's so many
ambiguities around it.
And then at some point you just
say, this is too much.
And that's why you went to,
like Java went multiple
interfaces light by having,
you can have multiple
interfaces.
Here's a concept that looks very
nice, but you had to work
-- it took five, 10 years
to realize that it's
actually not usable.
So if you to look at object
oriented languages, there have
been many languages.
This is an interesting thing,
because in parallel community
we haven't had this kind
of explosion out there.
Another interesting thing about
languages is language
has lot of relationship
and evolving.
So if you loot at from FORTRAN
that's started.
You can see the FORTRAN, so
this is FORTRAN in here.
To figure out what's happening
here, you can kind of trace
over the years how new languages
academically and
industrially came about.
Got influence from others, and
at then end up with things
like at the end of the graph
there's something you can
never read it.
But the key thing is, there's
all these influences going
across in there.
And cross fertilization.
At the end, you end up with
some TCL TK, Python --
I can't even read
it carefully.
Java, C sharp, PHP, and
stuff like that.
There are a lot of different
languages trying to get
influence in there.
The key thing is you need to
feed this beast. If you want
to have a lot of evolution or
even evolutionary changes.
What that means is, people say,
yeah, we have Java, C and
C , C sharp, we are happy
with languages.
No.
I think in the future to deal
with that you need to have
kind of revolution in there.
So if you look at something like
C , almost every language
started with FORTRAN.
And then there had been lot of
different influences that
happened to that.
And I'm going to just go, that's
for example, Java, it's
acknowledge that a lot of these
different languages
influenced ideas in there.
So why do we need new
languages in there?
I think we have paradigm
shifting architecture.
Because sequential to multicore
will require a new
way of thinking, and we kind of
need a new common machine
language for these
kind of machines.
And the new application
domains.
Because streaming is becoming
very interesting.
Scripting.
People are using things like
Python and PEARL and stuff
like that in a much
regular basis to
do much bigger things.
So those are cobbled
together languages.
But can you do better
in those things?
Real time.
Things like cell phones and
stuff become more important
how we deal with those issues.
And also new hardware
features.
Right now good language is tied
very well with the one
[OBSCURED]
hardware features in there.
So things like, for example,
black when I tell you that we
have all this wires available,
if you figure out some new way
of taking advantage
of those wires.
That hardware feature.
What's the software that can
really utilize that?
So you can just build a hardware
feature, but it's not
sufficient.
You have to have a software
that do that, too.
So what's the coupling?
A lot of things that
has to be that nice
interconnection there.
And I think there
are new people
who want mobile devices.
A great program.
If we would look at
parallelizing compilers or
parallelization as I said
before, was always geared to
this high performance weenies,
who just wanted to get their
global simulation going
as fast as possible.
Who has a multi-million dollar
supercomputer waiting.
It's very different having
things like great programmers
who want these things.
How do you cater to them?
They are very different.
The key thing is how can we
achieve parallelism without
burdening the programmer?
Because we don't, in this class
we barely burden you
guys and then you realize
how hard it is.
And how much complexity it adds
on top of the algorithm,
just to get it working
parallel.
So how do you reduce
some of the burden?
Perhaps not completely, but
reduce that burden.
I'm going to skip
some of this.
I'll make it available
on the site.
I want to have some time
for discussion.
In streaming, we talked
about it, we tried
to do some of that.
Tried to come up with the
programming model where it
will give you some additional
benefits for the program, at
the same time you can actually
get multicore performers.
And, of course, we saw that in
compilers we can actually get
good performance in then.
One thing that I did a long
time ago, is this SUIF
parallelizing compiler.
What we did was we can
automatically parallelize
FORTRAN programs all the way.
This kind of almost worked
in the 90's.
We, at some point, spec bench
marks were the way to measure
how good your world is, and
every company had 20 engineers
trying to get 5% of spec.
At the time our spec performance
was about 200.
Wire registered, we did this
compiler, that we could expect
bench mark performance at 800,
by just parallelizing.
And in fact we made this t-shirt
that said, spec red
and the number.
That's all the t-shirt said.
And, in fact, I was working in
a few places, including the
grocery store at Palo Alto,
and people stopped me and
said, how did you do that?
It's only on this kind
of weenie things.
And I had in the grocery story,
I had half an hour
conversation with [OBSCURED]
of how --
he was, like, hmm.
The only thing, spec 823.
That's the only two things
the t-shirt said, people
knew what it is.
But, there's problems. The
compiler was not robust. The
compiler can be used by the
people who wrote the compiler,
because we knew all the
things in there.
The thing about that is it
worked in a way that if
program worked, you get
8x improvement.
You change one line of
a code somewhere, you
went from 8x to 1x.
That, I think, stopped
parallelizing around the slow
[OBSCURED].
So now, normal programmer can
now understand what happens.
We go and analyze it and
afterward say aha, this is how
to change the program, how
to change the compiler.
So we just kind of developing
program and compiler at the
same time, and we could
use this thing.
You cannot ignore the fact
that this is happening.
Because there's so much of a
difference in performance.
That makes it even a curse.
I mean, if you only get 4x
improvement probably things
would have been better.
We should have probably capped
the performance or something.
And clients, in those days,
were impossible to with.
You saw a very good example
in last lecture.
OK.
Performance at any cost. I don't
want any of these tools
if it slows down at any time.
So how we deal with those
kind of people.
It's hard.
In multiprocessor, communication
was expensive.
If you make a wrong decision,
you pay a huge price.
Basically slow the
program down.
You go from being 1x, you
actually go from 0.5x.
And worse.
And you had to always deal
with Moore's law.
Why do I need to go all these
complicated compiling?
Can I just wait six months
and won't I get it?
They're probably right
at that time.
And another problem, what you
call a dogfooding problem.
The reason that object oriented
languages is very
successful is everybody who
did the object oriented
language, in order to get
accepted as a reasonable
language, had to write their own
compiler in that language.
And the compiler is a very good
way of really pushing
object oriented concepts.
And so almost every object
orientated language wrote
their compiler.
That's a really big thing
you have to write.
And by the time you write the
compiler you realize all the
problems of the language, and
you feel equal, because you
write a few hundred thousand
line programming of language.
Except all the people who were
doing high performance, we
were catering for
somebody else.
What that means is we can deal
with this weirdness, and say,
yeah it's no problem,
nobody --
but those are the things
that really kill
the users in there.
We didn't have the users
perspective.
And another thing that
today is these
things are really different.
Because you have complex data
structures, complex control
flow, complex build processes,
aliasing type unsafe languages.
All this cool things we used to
do, just became a hundred
times harder, because
of all those.
People fell in love with
data structures.
And they say, oh, they
were so nice.
We knew exactly the same size
thing, it doesn't change, I
could analyze it.
But malloc data structures,
it's just and very complex
trees and doubly linked
lists was just
impossible to deal with.
We want to go in the days where
everything is a nice
simple array But I guess the
paths for the compiler became
much harder in those days.
So I think compilers are a
critical thing to deal with.
I think if you have to improve
in multicores we had to deal
with compilers.
And the sad thing is some of
those things people are trying
to do it today by hand, we could
do it with the compilers
15 years ago.
We kind of lost that
technology.
And people are doing this
by hand again today.
And go back and dust off
this technology and
bring it back in there.
Best case, we might automate
everything.
And say, don't worry, do what
you are doing today and just
keep doing it and we'll get
multicore performance.
I don't think that's going
to be that realistic.
But in worse case, at least we
can help the darn programmers.
Tell them what's good,
what to do when they
do something wrong.
How can you build those
kinds of things.
I think that's very important.
I think in tool side,
we need tools.
I mean you realize after
programming on [OBSCURED]
that was really nice
to have your tools.
Everybody can probably come up
with some tools additions.
And I think tools, on this,
is pretty ancient.
How do you come up with really
good tools that the normal
programmer can use them?
Figure out problems, figure out
debugging issues and stuff
like that, and get
through together.
We need Eclipse type thing for
platform for multicores.
We have a lot of nice plug-ins
come about that actually help
you to do that.
Another interesting thing,
this is about
this dogfooding problem.
Normally what you come up with
language compiler tool, you do
implementation, you do
evaluation of that and you
cycle through that.
And evaluation says, ok, you
develop a program, you debug
the program for functionality.
Performance debugging, evaluate,
and everything kind
of go around that.
I mean there's a process here.
And you'd rather realize
somethings are very hard to
do, somethings are easy.
And you need that to basically
evolve that.
And the problem is --
I'm contrasting two things.
If you look at something
like CAD tools.
CAD tools were developed by
a bunch of guys sitting in
places, used by some very
different group of people.
Because of that, today's CAD
tools are horrendous to use.
Everyone hates them.
Because the people who developed
CAD tools never
thought about users.
They were indifferent.
And they just have to get the
functionality out and they
were happy after that.
Whereas, object oriented
languages were more thought
about as the how the
best way to use it.
Very much of a
programmer-centric phase.
And in that end, you develop a
system that's a lot easier to
use, a lot of people use it,
more acceptance in there.
The problem with high
performance languages is they
really sit in the
CAD tool way.
Because the people who write
high performance languages
never really use it.
People who write the compilers
and languages are not the ones
who are developing the high
performance programs. No high
performance language
ever wrote the
compiler in that language.
They say, oh, that's different
domain, we don't
know how to do that.
By doing that, you really never
expose the problems in
there, and I think the key thing
is how do you go about
doing that?
This is a hard problem.
Because how do get two different
groups together?
Perhaps multicores, what you
to do is you probably
everybody who write the
compiling tool, actually have
to write it in the thing that
you are doing, because you
need the parallelism.
At that point you realize all
the problems with the tool.
So I'm going to the
skip on this side.
Another interesting, very
interesting problem, that
people don't pay attention
is the migration
of the dusty deck.
Millions if not billions of
lines of code out there,
written in old styles way.
You've can't just say, look,
Microsoft, just go rewrite
everything new with my
spiffy new system.
That doesn't work.
How to get these people
to migrate out?
That might not mean doing
everything automatically, but
how can you even help -- the
people who wrote the code is
probably gone, left the company,
probably dead.
How do you help somebody move
some of these things to you.
That is the rate of evolution.
You don't have to rewrite
everything from scratch.
What kind of tools
that you can use?
And these applications
are still in use.
Sometimes source code is
even available, but
programs are gone.
But the interesting thing is,
some of those things,
applications have bugs that
have become features.
So I'll give you a very
good example.
And this happened
to Microsoft.
So at Microsoft at some point --
if you know Word, Word does
algorithmic pagination.
That means how to lay out the
pages, and how to break pages
and stuff like that.
So they had the algorithm
in there.
And they were switching
versions, and they said look,
this algorithm is now too old.
It's been there for
five, six years.
Rewrite it.
And of course you can assume
what the spec is.
There's a nice spec to
that, a few pages.
They said, go rewrite that.
And someone wrote a very nice
pagination algorithm.
But the problem is, when they
use that algorithm, a lot of
old documents broke.
That means they didn't
paginate right.
So the old document, when you
open it, looks very different.
And they said, darn,
what's going on?
What they realized is, the
old implementation
had a lot of bugs.
Subtle things.
The guide didn't really conform
to the standard.
So it didn't break the word
exactly right, if at some
point it has a break and space,
it would probably put
it on the next line.
A few things that
didn't really --
And what they had to do is,
they had to spend a lot of
time discovering bugs and
adding them to the spec.
So they did that.
Because otherwise, all the
previous program doesn't work,
the previous files will
not look right.
And they went through this
entire process of trying to
discover and trying to figure
out what [OBSCURED]
instead of what the text
of the specs said.
They're out of sync.
And so a lot of times,
there's that problem.
So you see we have something
old, and we
want to get it new.
It doesn't mean that you
know the functionality.
The functionality that was
implemented is the spec, or
the functionality that
you wrote about.
Because that's a little
bit subtly different.
So how do you go and
discover that.
I think that's a very
interesting
and important problem.
And I think there are many
reasons that run such things
like creating test cases,
extracting invariants, things
like failure oblivious computing
type, if you had
listened to professor
Rabbah's talk .
Things like that can help take
these old things and migrate.
Can use tools to do that.
I did a lot of interesting
research on that.
OK, so that's my take on
languages and compilers, where
interesting things
have happened.
I want to talk about revolution,
but I want to skip
that first and go into this
crossing the abstraction
boundaries part, and then
come back to revolution.
So the way the world works is,
you have some kind of class of
computing you want to do, and
you have some atoms that need
to run that computation.
That's basically the end
to end of any process.
But if I said, here's some
silicon, and here's my
algorithm, go do that, no single
person can basically
build that.
OK?
You can't take silicon, and
go through a semiconductor
process, build a process,
design all those things,
language -- it doesn't happen.
Someday probably it was possible
to have one person
know everything,
but you can't.
So what we have done deal with
build abstraction boundaries.
We have compilers, languages,
instruction,
microarchitecture, layout,
design rules, process,
materials science --
basically, everything
is separated out.
Every time one gets too
complicated, we kind of divide
it in half, and keep
adding and adding.
And we have this big
stack of things.
So at the beginning, then you
break up, people kind of knew
both sides, and they went
into one side and kind
of broke that up.
And so people knew
a lot of things.
But the next generation comes,
they only know that.
The guy, someone who's
going to be expert in
microarchitecture.
You only know microarchitecture.
He has no idea what the
languages are, because that
world of his is complicated.
What we have is a
compartmentalized world that
was broken up as we went in the
last 40 years, as things
progressed, the right thing at
that time, they figure out
what layers to do.
What we have done is create
the domain expert.
There's one guy who probably
knows about two things.
He might know a little bit of
design rules, and probably
process a little bit.
Another person will know a
little bit of design rules,
layout, and microarchitecture.
And there's someone who'll do
microarchitecture and ISA.
And somebody knows compilers
and ISA, but has no clue
what's happening.
So what this has done is kind
of entrenched some layering
that really made sense
about 30 years ago.
The problem now is, this
is creating a lot
of issues in here.
So what you kind of really need
is a way to break some of
this layering.
How do you do that?
You need people who can cross
multiple of these disciplines.
So this is a thing for you.
I mean, you might think
you are an architect.
But hey, you're in this class,
you're learning a little bit
of programming.
Go learn a little bit of
physics, what's in there.
Just have a little bit of
broadening in there.
Then a lot of people, there are
some people who are a lot
more in the process side, but
know a little bit about
microarchitecture
and compilers,
somewhere in the middle.
They are expert in the middle,
but they are not just sitting
happily in their own domain.
Just trying to look at
cross-cutting there.
And keep going up,
in some sense.
I kind of put myself in there,
saying OK, I am in compilers,
but I know a little bit
of language, and I
know a little --
I try to go down and down
as much as possible.
What you actually need is
someone who knows everything
really well.
That is hard, but at least
someone who can know the top
and the bottom to
redo the middle.
Because my feeling is the way
the middle is done is probably
now too old.
So I don't know that
this is possible.
It's not me.
But if someone really
understands the top and the
bottom, and say OK, I can
probably throw the middle out
and redo the middle.
And I think that might be an
interesting revolution that
might happen.
It's hard.
There's so much information
there.
Some of the information, there
are the layers out there, it
doesn't make sense, today,
the way things are.
I mean for example, a lot of
these layers had issues with
wire delay.
Because when wire delay was
not an issue, these layers
made perfect sense.
But as wire delay came about,
a lot of changes had to
propagate across layers, and
it was very hard, because
people were domain experts.
So I think this is where the
revolution is going to come.
Somebody's going to [OBSCURED]
the way you do compilers, the
way you do architecture, the
way you decide everything
is wrong.
I know the algorithms
you want to run.
I know what's available in
very low [OBSCURED].
Let me see you put
that together.
A person, a group, whatever.
Might have a beginning.
And so with that, I will go
to the revolution side.
So the way you look at
revolutions, what are the
far-out technologies?
And sometimes revolutions just
come from wishful thinking.
I wish we can do this, and then
if you can push hard, you
might be able to get there.
Anybody wants to -- so in this
talk I talk way too much.
How about, come in?
What do you think is
going to happen?
What do you want to work on?
You guys are the ones who have
to make this decision.
Not me.
I've already made a lot of
decisions myself, 10, 15 years
ago, what I'm going to do.
You are in the process,
you have a lot
more choices to make.
You haven't narrowed
your horizon yet.
So this affects a lot more on
you than me at this point.
What do you think is going
to change the world?
What do you want to work on?
I mean, you should work on
something, I guess, that you
think is going to have
a huge impact.
Have you thought about that?
A lot of silence.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: So faster means
very little latency.
Latency is a hard problem.
A lot of people who are trying
to do latency [OBSCURED]
And the revolution side people
are looking at quantum can
kind of do deal with latency.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yes, I think there
are a lot of revolutionary
things you can do there.
Especially taking advantage of
the fact that you have a lot
of wires in there.
And I think people haven't
really pursued that yet.
And this is where the complexity
will come in.
Trying to basically deal with
these, take advantage of these
kind of things.
I think there are a lot of
opportunities there.
And then that's the kind
of evolutionary part.
And then some people
are looking at
revolution, with quantum.
What else?
I expected people to have a lot
more interesting insights.
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: I think the world
is almost bifurcated.
There are things that you can
have with power plugs, and
things that don't have
power plugs.
And I think people who have
power plugs still have some
power issues, like what
Google is finding out.
You can't just keep
wasting power.
But as things start becoming
more mobile, going into
smaller and smaller devices,
power and size becomes a much
bigger thing than what
more you can do.
You don't become performance, I
mean, you want some level of
performance; you need
to get a video.
But the minute you get the
video, you don't want to have
HD TV. You just say, OK,
get the media onto
my cellphone screen.
I'll be happy with that speed.
Just do it.
As low power as possible,
as [OBSCURED]
possible.
So I think that's
pushing there.
So for example, in for a long
time what has happened is
there's a trickle
down economy.
Things that start happening in
a very high end system and
kind of trickle down
to the low end.
But there might be
a diversion here.
There might be a different
part coming.
Because that technology might
be fundamentally different.
AUDIENCE: So [OBSCURED]
also changing from the software
side is this notion
of perpetual data.
I've been using this mash-up
code, you put it up on the
web, lots of people use it.
So it's pushing toward
scripting light
languages or whatever.
PROFESSOR: So this is an
interesting obsession I have.
So [OBSCURED]
And then a few years ago I had
a start up, and I just again
had the time to try it,
not large , some
large piece of code.
What I realized was, what
programming had become, is the
biggest, best tool for
programming at
that time was Google.
Because I was trying a bunch
of things with Windows.
And everything I want,
there was a function.
And if I can find that function,
my work is a factor
of 100 smaller.
So I spend more time than
actually thinking about
algorithms, how the lists should
be, or how my data
structures should be,
trying to Google it.
I said, darn, I want
to do this.
Where's that function?
Where can I find that function
in this entire big library.
So what that means is
there's kind of this
missing layer in there.
Because what has happened is,
our language is a level of
abstraction.
And then we have built these
libraries with no kind of
support at all.
I mean, the compilers' languages
don't really support
the libraries.
Because it's just built
out of basic blocks.
And keeping it, can you have
better basic blocks, can you
have more nice abstraction?
Instead of saying, OK, here's
5,000 libraries with 250,000
different functions that you
can use for compiling.
Can you build it
in a nicer way?
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
interface, your input,
your output.
And then you publish your
code and then Google
indexes it for you.
And then your program is just
of Google searches.
PROFESSOR: I think, if you
think about what all the
Windows source base is,
it's like that.
I mean, in the company we were
doing, during the [OBSCURED],
there was this group of people
who understood every line of
code they wrote, because they
were writing a virtualization
system that runs
on the Windows.
So for them, every line
was probably --
Interesting thing is, when
that group started, that
entire piece of code was
about 50,000 lines.
Now it's about 65,000 lines.
But we had about 10 people
working on that.
That means these things
get revised.
You don't keep at it.
There's another group of
people who's doing user
interface and stuff like that.
they have alphabet soup of
different libraries.
They're using Ajax,
this, that --
I don't even know what
they are using.
The amount of code they
write is immense.
The amount of things they
have to know is immense.
Each of them are not
that completed.
But if you use a bad thing,
you have a bad looking
interface, clunky, slow,
whatever, if you figure out
the right three function calls,
things look much better.
That's a very different type
of programming in there.
So for them, it's basically
knowledge.
How much do you know.
Just like, it's almost like I
remember my college days,
friends who were doing things
like that in medical school.
So you need to know this entire
thing about all the
different muscles in the body.
And there's this big thick
book you just study.
It's almost like that.
You just take this big Windows
manual that are a few hundred
pounds heavy, and you look at
every page, and figure out
what you know.
That's a really strange
way of coding.
But, I mean, algorithmically,
I think what they were doing
is pretty simple.
I don't think they every
designed a data structure.
Every data structure they used
came from something.
But they had to figure out
the right data structure.
AUDIENCE:
This is going in a totally
different direction, but in
terms of graphics in video
games, perhaps getting artists
who are aware of both the
hardware and the software, and
so can design more for the
capabilities of the machine,
and can make more visually
appealing --
PROFESSOR: I think that's the
are that has a very different
set of communities.
Artists [OBSCURED].
Not even trained engineers.
And they're sitting in one,
and they have this neat
feature, they want fire
to look natural,
or whatever it is.
And then there's the programmers
and hardware
people, that who knows what
the capability is.
I think that's what we're
trying to push in Mike
Eckham's talk, and say how
do you go about it?
How do you know when a new thing
comes, what is doable?
Like for example, what ATI does,
ATI has a group called
the research group.
What they do is, every time a
new chip comes, they actually
go and figure out all the things
you can do with that.
OK, how can you do
rain in this one?
So they write a lot of --
those of a little bit of an
artistic bent, but very
hard-core programmer who kind
of figure out what's doable.
And they make that available
and say here, this is
what you can do.
And a lot of people kind
of emulate that.
They say, wait a minute,
how did they do that?
Then kind of figure out, OK, now
I have this new hardware,
and I'm able to do something
completely new.
I think that's, pushing there.
I mean, I think this is
where interesting
revolutions come about.
One of my firm beliefs is that
a lot of good research is not
in one area, as I pointed out.
It's kind of looking at two
distinct things and kind of
bringing them together.
Bringing knowledge from
one to another
and mixing them together.
I think that can have
huge impact.
And that's a place that I think
can have huge impact.
What other things that will
have big visual impact?
That the next hardware
can enable?
You can keep adding more big
servers and stuff like that,
but it's another thing.
What other things can
can have big impact?
AUDIENCE:
[OBSCURED]
The same is true for biologists,
physicists,
chemists, end users.
So maybe the thing to do is work
on language generators.
And easy way for me as an end
user to express language
[OBSCURED]
that I want and give me
a way to generate it
PROFESSOR: So that's
a lot of things.
For example, I was talking to
this computational biologist.
And what he said was, for
computer science, the best
thing that happened from a
biology point of view is Excel
only had 32,000 cells.
Because the biologists
keep using Excel, and
they say that --
AUDIENCE: [OBSCURED]
PROFESSOR: 65,000 cells.
And they ran into this and
said, jeez, I can't do
anything more in that.
Now what do I do?
And then suddenly they had to
start looking at programming
and stuff like that, because
they can't have an Excel
spreadsheet doing that.
So that's a lot of biologists
actually had to switch.
So I think, interesting thing
about computer sciences, there
are a lot of fundamental
sciences still.
But I think we have grown and
ran so fast developing that,
what's lagging behind that
is applications.
How to apply that to biology,
gaming, stuff like that.
And I think a lot of interesting
things, as
computer scientists, we can do
is to bring that knowledge in
an applied community.
Really, you can have a huge
impact and fundamentally
change things if you apply
that knowledge.
Both theoretical things you have
to get out, as well as
using the powers of the
computers we've got
in the right way.
I think a lot of times, people
are taking a few days to do
two times better, five times
better than kind of seeing
fundamentals [OBSCURED].
I think this is an interesting
topic.
I think I'm going
to stop soon.
And I think it's interesting,
especially for you guys.
Because you are probably going
into an area, looking at a
field, trying to get expert
at something.
There's a lot of times you get
seduced to become an expert in
what's hot today.
But the interesting thing is,
especially if you are doing a
PhD, or if you do something that
takes four or five years
for you to mature in that area,
is it going to be the
hardest thing in four
or five years?
So multicores are hard today.
So should I recommend that
everybody jump and become
expert and try to do a
PhD in multicores?
Probably not.
Because five or six years down
the line, some of these things
might be solved. they'd better
get solved, or else we're in
big trouble.
But the thing is, what's going
to be the problem there?
I see one thing that's really
hard, it's almost art, is to
kind of picture your
[OBSCURED]
and then if your lucky And if
you're lucky and you do a good
job in that prediction, you've
come about, and by the time
you get to a point that you
become expert, you've become
expert in the thing that's
most important.
It's not an easy thing to do.
And a lot of times, nobody can
claim that they have a
technique to do that, too.
A lot of people who claim,
they discount
how lucky they were.
There's a large amount of
luck associated with it.
But a key thing is to kind of
follow that trend, identify,
and do that.
That's the technique that I
think every one of us, every
one of you should do a lot.
OK.
With that, do you have something
about the --
SPEAKER: Yes.
A couple of things about --
Anybody here want direct access
to a Playstation 3?
Just one?
Two?
So come by, actually if you
have time now, we'll talk
about that and figure
out a way of getting
you access to it.
The final competition's going
to be this Thursday.